If you take a quick look at this
so you don't see anything.
Okay.
The only thing that might give it away
is this part what we glued it again
so that it's an indication
that somebody opened it up and glue it up
back again.
Now, you can see the here the vein.
If I can call it.
So one substance here, and the other one
might be on the other side.
All right.
We have a white powder
right here.
We're going to start
because we've got to make sure
that this is not fentanyl
so what we're going to do right now,
we're going to test it.
So we've got the goggles,
the chase mask, just to make sure.
And that's
what we're going to do. Stay safe.
All right.
Cocaine.
So we know it's cocaine.
It's not as toxic as fentanyl.
So we're going to try to extract that.
See how much weight.
And as you can see,
Brown is going to be left.
Going to take us a long time to do it.
But that's okay.
Okay.
And we save the day
Well, the good thing about this
is that once
you start getting the hang of,
it becomes easier and faster.
So how many we got? One.
there should be two or three,
at least four.
All right. I think we've got everything.
So we're going to go and start waiting
and find out
how much cocaine we have
out of the 15 parcels.
14 came positive.
So we will wait 14 parcels
and find out how much drug do we have
And there's going to be 89 grams
94. This is 100.
regardless of how small
or how big the cocaine shipment is.
We all were trying to intercept it
because it's always going to cause harm
to our community.
Okay, last one.
And we're done.
That's going to be over 14 back
86.
One and one half kilogram of cocaine.
Today we accomplish our mission.
Tomorrow's another day and tomorrow
we will do it all over again.
You mail it. We're going to nail it.